a Milano Ci sono 3 cose sacre e il Don
La Madonnina e il pane tu altro che
quella porcheria con lo zucchero a velo
sopra se all uvetta e canditi Preferisci
il pandoro te Sei proprio un pirla che
poi questione di gusti Eh per carità ma
il panetun de Milan al dolce per
eccellenza di Natale e in più allenato
ai tempi di Ludovico il Moro mica
l'altro ieri è colta Milanese a parte
che pandeoro si mangiava dai tempi della
Venezia dei Dogi Ghetto capio e poi è
questione di gusti Infatti sono tutti
d'accordo il pandoro se proprio un altro
pianeta sei così buon che non cambia
bisogno di tutte quelle robe là che
mettete voi altri dentro uvetta canditi
sito mata e poi specialità di Verona
città dell'amore essa forma di stella
Perché
sai come si dice da queste parti magna
E taci Ma va a cagher